till you start this one off how to do
mutter every people of the world welcome
to another episode of genius brain where
we be talking about some genius type of
materials some [ __ ] that's true
so you [ __ ] you uh you got
invited out to the McDonald's
headquarters right yes this [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's so it's you know what it's
getting to the point now where I just
think they're doing it on purpose to
piss me off because there's absolutely
no [ __ ] way that I should not have
been invited by now I'm like okay so I
think recently Casey got a deal yeah
what the [ __ ] but it's it's from a
different group yes so the group that
brought out Gina is the same group that
brought me out and then bhar jiyo hasn't
got one either and I will Julia hasn't
got one either and I don't know every I
mean I asked him about it too but I mean
I was hand selected so I mean no you
know what it is like a fine jewel you
know what it would it what it was I did
a lot of free promo for them before yeah
so like you know after everybody was
like spots or JK or their Instagram
right um they you know a couple months
ago they sent me like a bunch of gift
cards in like they gave me some like
like letters and envelopes and like I
never even got that yeah and from o to
instantly right yeah well they gave me
that stuff to just start giving to
people and then they sent me like a 365
like booklet of a bunch of free like
gifts and I just started giving so much
to people that I think like I was just
on the radar because I put in work for
them I put in work to get free [ __ ] like
I just kept you know I'm gonna put in a
word for you because what I ended up
doing was I asked them like hey you know
JK has a bigger audience and I was like
why don't you you know that would be
better for you in a JK news do you know
if David so did you see do you see this
man I lost weight on McDonald's you know
what though I was actually the biggest
one they're like really well they were
bringing in different people like in
waves and then most of them were food
bloggers and stuff like food Instagram
know this was just a strictly Instagram
Pro me to see this what I'm saying like
I am
everything I I'm a food guy yeah I also
have great content and I have like a
million subscribers like oh what else do
you [ __ ] want I own restaurants like
I promote the [ __ ] you know what this is
what it is jacking the bus what's up
yeah no I shouldn't say that
I just just throw me anything I don't
kick it throw me up give me a [ __ ]
head you know what I'm I think they're
saving the best for last then and there
they're just working up the steps is
what's what's happening I want them to
give me a McDonald's pen so I could
write my feelings on a piece of
McDonald's paper that's all I want I'm
not even asking for much more
recognizable cuz they know it bothers me
and it's getting under my skin that's
what it is you know they they watch our
stuff like and they thought they thought
it was hilarious like like you know yeah
they get bombarded though you know what
it's it it's not McDonald's directly
yeah like they have agencies that take
care of their marketing well so
marketing yeah bucks look at me dude I
love you guys thanks for the thanks for
the opportunity and I would love you to
if you give me the same opportunity I am
a food food fat ambassador I'm a fat
ambassador you know it's crazy they have
a restaurant like just to do filming in
absolutely so this they have this huge
building right it's like I don't know
like 15 floors or whatever it's huge and
then the bottom floor is like this it's
like a regular McDonald's but it has
like international products that you
rotate so when I was there they had like
matcha matcha latte they had like all
kinds of different stuff we had matcha
latte so you got you got to sample [ __ ]
that nobody else had well that they have
that in Japan so sometimes like yeah so
sometimes they'll have things from
Australia like the shaker fries or
whatever or like you know they'll just
bring in different products she's out
there living my damn food and then and
then I was at the hamburger University
where they train all of their like
hamburger specialists what's it like to
be human I just got to go there get the
sample all these treats and then they
have a restaurant built in just for
filming so really yeah and I think
that's like the test place where they
teach all the franchise owners like how
like work the registers and like the
system like the kitchen and all that
stuff really yeah and they use that for
filming too
what the [ __ ] is hamburger University
well hamburger University is their
school like when you're a franchise
owner your goal get burglar comes out
and [ __ ] professor hamburger yeah [ __ ]
no like they just come out and then they
I guess like once you own a franchise
you got to learn how to run it you got a
you know they want you to be like
franchising schools but they teach you
how the system is yeah yeah do you know
how much it costs to franchise at
McDonald's I don't know but I think you
could check out on entrepreneur.com and
last time I checked like 10 years ago it
was like you have to have a million
dollars so it's a seven-figure franchise
yeah like not only a million dollars in
assets but like a million dollars cash
or something like that what the [ __ ] it
was it was some big amount of money I
was like I was like nah this is too much
it's crazy I mean I'm pretty sure
because it's like a definite that it's
going to do well yeah I've never seen in
McDonald's closed down unless like a
homeless person I lit it on fire
which I did see once yeah you're right I
haven't seen anything Donald's closed
down yeah I've never seen the McDonald's
closed down because it wasn't successful
I've only seen it get burnt down that's
it yeah it's crazy man I mean what I
love about it is like they're consistent
with their product and that's hard to do
yeah well it's easy to make trash
consistent I'm kidding it's trash to
everybody else but it's not trash to me
it's golden nuggets which is better no
but that's what it is it's not like this
is why I get so upset when people when
also for example like I was out in Miami
for scent foods yeah and we were
shooting and then the sound guy was like
we stopped by and we're we're going on
the way back we didn't have enough time
to get the crew a meal so we're like
yeah whatever you guys want to eat just
let us know so we can give you a quick
bite before we stop off and that was
McDonald's yeah and then she was like oh
there's a McDonald you guys just wants
to be quick he goes what that's you want
to feed a sawdust on the hold on [ __ ]
what you mean somebody was saying one
guy I was like what you mean sawdust son
Wow oh [ __ ]
the disrespect I've never heard at first
of all to sawdust I think like the
perception of like fast food so weird
they go oh that's not real food then
what the [ __ ] am i [ __ ] out of my
ass that's some real [ __ ] you better
shut the [ __ ] up but that you know
people expect I don't know what they
expect from a fast food joint you know
they go right this is do you know what
it does to your body there's a lot of
bad thing
like just because you the snicker you
wait at home this terrible [ __ ] to your
body to the microwave dinner you ain't I
mean yes like it's different levels yeah
the hot cheetos you just ate - is that
any what's the damn difference yeah I
think what do they expect like some
[ __ ] Gordon Ramsay ass like super or
steamed food or that's what I'm saying I
know what McDonald's is for if I want to
get a 99 cents officer of cone and some
chicken nuggets and some fries I know
where to get real quick it's a snack I
mean it's not meant to be like you know
you eat it three times a day
exactly any fast food any fast food yeah
I'm saying it's there to just enjoy from
time to time and like they even they
even say that too like it's like please
don't promote like gluten II like I mean
like just good any like just massively
eating and stuff it's like it's not you
know really meant to be that kind of
stuff of course yeah that's why I'm
saying well you know what's cool though
you know what's cool is that they have
so they have they're like chefs that are
like the inventors they have chefs yeah
so they sit down and like so I got to
taste like what a chicken nugget what a
you know quarter like quarter pounder
like what are these supposed to taste
like made by the best of the best and no
doesn't eat of Todd's dude even when
it's cold like we were just sitting
there mind blown like how is this it's
like perfectly fried perfectly
everything and in the meat that they use
at the headquarters they use like this
like prime like Oh me I mean it's it's
the guys it's it's like different yeah
it's like prime me like it's good mean
so I was just like wow dude this is
crazy like so what they create in that
kitchen that they're trying to replicate
that in mass production yes but I think
the difference is it was fresh yeah so
like if you've noticed like when you go
to a regular you know McDonald's right
down the street or whatever right
sometimes the fries aren't good
sometimes they're good yeah there's
there's a difference I mean there's a
slight difference in it's because the
fries were fresh more like you know it
was just made right now yeah so I think
when you try it when it's made at that
moment it tastes so damn good yeah you
get lucky sometimes with McDonald's
french fries every dollar has your
favorite yep did you know you can ask
them to make it fresh what you can ask
them yeah I want to fry
batch don't be like okay well we're
gonna make a new one or they're like
okay we just made one or you could wait
a little bit yeah yeah I didn't know
that right no [ __ ] clue that's
[ __ ] wild yeah it's like a secret
that's crazy dude yeah that was out and
um because when you were doing that I
remember that day you flew out and then
I flew out to Florida it was where were
you at me at Miami I was in Fellsmere
Florida the hels belles Mir and then I
was also out in Miami yeah in Miami so
Fellsmere Miami and then where the [ __ ]
was that other place it was it was like
a coastal city though but it was a city
I never really heard but Miami was like
a three-hour drive from there what was
it for
it was for sin food so we were doing
that show where we travel see this one
say I do food damn it so the show is now
sold another company acquired and we'll
be releasing our first episodes in
February with that company on their
Channel that's dope and we basically
travel and we go to all these different
food festivals all across the United
States and so we got there do it first
of all three-hour delay yo let me tell
you about the [ __ ] dude let me tell you
about the [ __ ] real quick was it like
Stormin and [ __ ] no it wasn't it was
beautiful out there but we had a
three-hour [ __ ] delay and listen I'm
not saying this is coming from a big guy
right like I've been big my whole
[ __ ] life and one thing that if
people don't know this we tend to be a
lot smellier than other people so we
have to be a little more careful about
bathing ourselves right we just gotta
wash our crevices a little more
sometimes make people smell like [ __ ]
I'm telling you this as fact from from
me you know so we just got to be a
little careful about it
i when I was sitting down there was this
big couple very nice we're not talking
about their personality but I was
sitting down on the floor and their
group got called before me yeah and
they're they're quite large to the point
where they have like I think one of them
had like a walking stick or whatever
right and young couple - yeah as they
walk by I get a whiff of something that
smelled just like toe jam no I went I
started I started gagging I'm like what
the [ __ ] was that smell and looked
around it was those two that walk by me
I'm like oh [ __ ] what and you know I
always have tend to have bad luck on
these flights have whether it's like no
so check this out so I sit down and I
see these people
people there and I what I mean by big is
that there are two people but they have
to take up three seats oh that big that
big yeah and so I'm like okay like I
know what it is like to be a big guy
that makes sense you know it's gonna be
a more comfortable flight for them so I
sit down and talk please don't let music
be sitting next to them I'm in the seat
in front of them and they smelled so
[ __ ] bad so bad to the point I
couldn't lean back in my seat cuz I
would just smell it
Oh so I had a lean forward on the TV
with my forehead pressed on the screen
just so I could breathe and it smelled
so [ __ ] bad dude I was dying I was
[ __ ] dying dude were people around
you like oh my god I'm pretty sure they
were teasing next to Tim no Tim was
sitting somewhere else you know what Tim
got the best luck on earth dude like the
last fight that we had you understand
yeah so we we sat down I didn't see him
anywhere you know what happened upgraded
to first class why because he's [ __ ]
Timothy DeLaGhetto that's all mine and
I'm just [ __ ] David so oh you guys
aren't even City with next to each other
when you fly because we both like window
seats oh you see I used to like window I
like aisle now I like either or aisle or
window so I just need that extra space I
just can't be in the middle yeah yeah
yeah I don't like the middle either yeah
so window it's it's kind of tight but I
need the extra legroom cuz I'm so
[ __ ] tall yeah so I like the whole
flight I had a lean for and press my
head against the screen in front because
I couldn't breathe if I lean back that's
not legit smelled like toe jam like co
Jam it was [ __ ] disgusting man and I
don't know how to in that situation how
do you bring up to somebody that they
smell I mean they can't do anything it's
like one of those things where if
someone just [ __ ] their pants they
already [ __ ] their pants yeah we're
gonna say she's gonna be like hey you
stink it's like I kind of know that bro
exactly like do I come up to him say
excuse me sir you smell like the [ __ ]
between my toes you fat [ __ ] like what
do I say to them to make it feel better
nothing they probably know that they
smell yeah and I'm not gonna what I mean
to make them feel bad about it they
might be so fat that they can't scrub
that's what I was think it was like this
guy had a big as metal bucket like it
was huge it's it's it's like the [ __ ]
that you'd like water you give water
like Cal's and and [ __ ] you know pigs
and horses like yeah
huge tub right and then this fool was
taking a bath by like filling it up with
dishwashing soap he uses dishwashing
soap yeah he sits in there and his dad
has to help scrub him like he's a
big-ass cow if you if you go on Netflix
I'm not sure if this documentary still
there but it's it's based in the UK
where they're following people who are
morbidly obese yeah and I at the time
loved watching these shows because I
wanted it to motivate me to lose weight
cuz I was big too and I was like I gotta
wash this [ __ ] so it scares me [ __ ]
skinny and that's what I thought it was
gonna do but there was a scene that made
me laugh so hard and it wasn't supposed
to be funny but the guy was with his
wife right and I think she's from a
Muslim household yeah so she's very I
guess like she attends to the husband
really well I see and so sometimes he
gets a little verbally abusive with her
but it was kind of funny because he was
so fat he was in this reclining chair
and she left one of the screen doors
open and there was mosquitoes biting his
legs but he was so fat that he couldn't
reach down this despite the [ __ ]
mosquitoes sitting there and he's like
you think this is funny cuz his wife's
laughing does I guess yeah I'm getting
my legs like I'm like I kind of wonder
too like when you watch these shows you
kind of wonder how somebody gets to that
size yeah cuz even when I was getting up
to like I was like 265 pounds like I
felt it like you it's so hard to ignore
and it's and I think it's the people
around I'm enabling I'm like there's got
to be someone cooking and bringing the
food because if they're the size of this
room like they're not getting up in
making the food and getting it someone's
bringing it to Mum yeah so 100% yeah and
like the the amount of calories that
they're ingesting it's it's ridiculous
I've so I have a friend in Sacramento
who um he's a really really large guy
still to this day he's a really really
big guy and he like Branagh is somewhere
over the rainbow he's close to it but he
could walk it he's you know he's
functioning F and then he works at a
hospital whatever I kind of ironic but
so whenever I had a conversation with
him you know he would talk about losing
weight and getting fit and then when we
would hang out I would watch him eat
look he's eating much and he goes yeah I
don't really eat that much but I keep
getting bigger now physiologically
speaking that's [ __ ] impossible yeah
the calories in that you put will be
reflected in your body unless you have
like a thyroid issue or something very
specific right so every time we we hung
out it just looked like he didn't eat
much yeah he goes like oh I'm full I'm
done and he would have kind of pushed
the food aside
oh [ __ ] like he he's pretty good at
moderating his food but so we went to a
downtown Sacramento we all got smashed
when he got drunk I got to see how much
he actually eats so when he's drunk
that's when he craves and that's when he
craves or that's when he's not
bullshitting and lying to us so either
he's he's lying to himself and he's also
lied to us as well yeah so I [ __ ] you
not we first started with the pitcher of
beer we split it between me and two
other people it was him and another guy
split it drank it split another one and
then at that point he was getting a
little tipsy then he ordered a pitcher
to himself he drank a whole picture by
himself you know we're just you know
egging him on like I can't drink that
[ __ ] yeah and he drank the whole [ __ ]
picture to himself and then later we
went to this diner in Sacramento called
Opie's original parries it's like a
truck or diner right and I got to see
how much he ate this dude ate the
country fried steak dinner which by the
way a trucker diner yeah huge right
right his plates
I can eat like half and I'm full exactly
he eats that he's a stack of [ __ ]
pancakes look that he look then he eats
a you know the Denny's Superbird they
have a version of that where it's like a
BLT with you he eats that with curly
fries a bunch of ranch and he finishes
all of it holding hot chocolate and soda
dude that's like a week's worth of food
for me in one [ __ ] city and I was
like yo that's how you eat that's what
it was so this whole time you know
whatever the two three years ago that I
had with them you just never saw him
really eat I never got to see it I think
cuz he was ashamed and so you know when
he shows us he was telling us he doesn't
eat a lot but I saw him eat three
[ __ ] meals in one [ __ ] sitting
dude think like two days worth of food
like I'm sitting there and my mouth is
just like I was surprised that somebody
like that can eat so like a human being
can yeah so people tend to like you know
we all do this too we
sometimes we're more embarrassed you
know we'll say things just to kind of
say face yeah but I it with him because
he is a relatively open guy that he
would be honest with me but that just
shows that he no matter how open and
cool he is on the outside his
insecurities aren't there right because
he's kind of faking how much he eats
it's like why do you even need to do
that yeah and I and I bought into it
because it's he's a very confident dude
very funny guy but he does have an
insecurity about his way and he still
struggles with it till this day crazy
it's [ __ ] wild you know one of my
guilty pleasure is watching these like
big guy shows is like the moment that
they have to cut out the drywall to put
them on a second dolly and like they
have to put these guys like on a
forklift to get them out there was a guy
was he lived with his mom right and then
you they they put out on him on a table
how much he eats for breakfast pack it
was like a whole pack like two packs of
bacon yeah it was a whole loaf of like
Wonder Bread yeah like a case of eggs
yeah I saw I think I seen the same one
they get the the [ __ ] big pack at
Costco for the eggs yeah yeah it's like
crazy and I remember like back in a day
remember those those shows like Janie
Jones and yeah they would always have
like the obese section and I was a kid I
would wait for that moment that they
would cut out the wall and have to bring
them out that I just wait for that
moment I just wait I'm like oh when are
they gonna like bust down the door so
they could like I just want to see the
whole house break down that literally
means that they were living in like
confinement yeah X amount of years that
they they can physically can't not go
through the [ __ ] door you know take
some like six hours to take a [ __ ] yeah
like some of the bathrooms they have to
custom build or like they can't even
move to the bathroom they just need to
go in a bucket or something and that's
the crazy thing too because that's
exactly what you were saying somebody is
enabling that be somewhere so big they
can't even walk to the fridge to eat yep
even if they want you know it's also
dangerous to to immediately cut the
calories
oh yeah cuz cuz he can die oh [ __ ] yeah
it's like extreme it's like both
extremes like you know how during the
cause there were people that were
starving and GIS that the soldiers that
were coming in and they were like holy
[ __ ] I feel so bad
and he gave him like chocolate they gave
him like something like oh yeah their
body just immediately couldn't take that
kind of calorie and they died oh really
I was like their insulin spike and all
this [ __ ] happened and it just shocked
their body because they were so long
without eating and that's the same way
with like eating a lot like if you're
used to taking in like 10,000 20,000
calories right yeah and all of a sudden
you starve yourself then literally you
are starving yourself like and if you
drop down to like 2,000 calories your
body's in shock cuz it's like it's used
to getting like an X amount of calories
to keep everything working I wonder if
like UFC fighters go through the same
thing then right because they go on such
a huge calorie of water cut maybe they
have to get to it yeah I mean I heard
that the guys are fighting injured
delirious dehydrated like a lot of them
you know they're there a lot of that
it's water weight and you're dehydrated
cuz you can't drink any water and you're
[ __ ] doing everything yeah that's
that just crazy man it's the other show
that I like chickens you know Biggest
Loser yeah [ __ ] loser was at the time
so Netflix had like I don't know I think
it was like 20 seasons of it or
something ridiculous love that on
Netflix and I would watch that show just
for motivation but I heard the tactics
that they use to get them to lose weight
was super unethical it's [ __ ] up and
yeah why didn't that show - made me feel
bad because these people would lose like
60 pounds in a week it's the diet pills
but it's a dangerous like diet pills
that's been proven - like [ __ ] people
III read this article - when I was like
binge watching and this was I was in
k-town like years ago and I was reading
articles just to follow up on some of
the contestants that I really liked on
the show to see where they were at now
and it was like I would say like over
half of them either gain their weight
back yep or they gain even more yeah
it's kind of stress the stress you know
they whatever it is that they did to
their body and I think like with that
extreme type of weight loss I mean easy
come easy go right or something like
that and the show would [ __ ] with them
too and then like get them to relapse
because
they want the drama they want them to
cry about like being disappointed in
themselves and all that [ __ ] yeah it was
it was a sad show man I mean it was
funny to us but like though when you
learn about what the [ __ ] happened
behind the scenes yeah yeah and then a
lot of them were pressured to take diet
pills like behind the scenes like their
agents and stuff would just try to like
come on just take it
oh really and then you could read this
up like online like there's a lot of
people that are kind of like suing them
and they came out like yeah I was
pressured of taking diet pills and like
losing a lot of weight really fast and
in like that's the sad part too because
it doesn't teach you good habits nah I
mean it's all entertainment right like
they wanted to create a good show with
drama and you know responsible people
don't make good drama yeah like if
everybody was like level-headed
disciplined and then you know they were
good like that's not a show a show is
like all is let's see let's let's kind
of watch them fail so then I don't have
to feel so bad about myself yeah I think
the the name reality or the title
reality TV show kind of makes people
think that everything is how it's
supposed to be there's always somebody
behind they're pulling [ __ ] strings
right it's right puppet master right
like like all those reality TV shows
that do really well there is a producer
out there there is a director you know
trying to get people to do what they
want them to do yep and so I mean it
goes as far as to like when they're
doing casting they get a psychologist so
like I mean in the industry we call it
unscripted right like yeah they're
scripted and unscripted and unscripted
is reality TV and like when you get like
the old-school stuff like what was that
real the MTV one the not the real house
oh [ __ ] uh I know what you're talking
about yeah yeah yeah what [ __ ] Jamie
Chung was on it she said she got big off
that [ __ ] they would film that in a set
Oh
they built a set that looks like a home
and then they they were acting oh and
then on top of that like let's say you
get these like like a rehab house or
like you get like some kind of
people to get together and they have to
stay in his home even if they do film it
out a house right they specifically look
for conflicting personalities because
they want drama so they get a
psychologist and they'll be like okay
this guy's this kind of personality like
this guy has OCD and this guy's messy as
[ __ ] so they're gonna fight about that
so they come in and do that like they
just they just figure out really shitty
ways on how to like [ __ ] with people for
entertainment there was another show
called Big Brother yeah that [ __ ] you
just watched it cuz I wanted to see you
scared when I [ __ ] like all these people
that [ __ ] soon yeah I would just wait
cuz I'm like hold that bitch's [ __ ]
like I [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of them dude
I saw one where it was like a bunch of
sex addicts that were trying to be
abstinent in a home and everybody was
[ __ ] everybody I forgot what it was
called what you sure that wasn't on
Playboy TV or something I was just like
what the hell like of course they're
gonna [ __ ] each other but it was like a
sex rehab house they had a show on
Playboy TV called I think I was like
called swing house or swingers or some
[ __ ] like that
you remember that none okay so it was a
show basically where couples would come
in and they'd really want to try swings
super bad and they're hyper sexually
active human beings and they would have
from whatever a member I think like porn
stars were there to just to get them
comfortable yeah and they had a room
towards the end of the episode where
they would just all [ __ ] each other and
they talked about it and it was so funny
there's this one episode that I saw and
there was a guy and she's talking about
their experiencing you know usually the
guys like it when the girl gets [ __ ]
yeah by somebody else whether it's a guy
or a girl is sometimes they have
different rules depending on the person
is but this is what I mean I pretty sure
you guys can look it up it's probably
somewhere on the internet but there's a
guy sitting there with his girlfriend as
she's talking about how there was this
black dude that wanted the [ __ ] she
was like yeah but his dick was really
big and he's just sitting there just
smiling like okay okay at first it
looked like you didn't bother too much
he goes and it stretched me out really
hard and that is she goes it hurt but he
was kind of a good type of she just get
going he's just sitting there's cut a
knot
oh my you probably kind of regret this a
little bit so she was just talking about
how much she loved [ __ ] the other guy
oh that's crazy because usually what
would happen is that they have like set
rules like sometimes there would be a
guy I don't know I think in that same
episode there was a guy that only
allowed his girlfriend to [ __ ] other
girls but yeah other guys and the girl
would have sometimes rules for the guys
to it so you could only [ __ ] a girl that
I allow you to [ __ ] though you know what
the more you talk about it I feel like
I've seen this it was really popular on
play was it shot at the Playboy Mansion
it was shot in a house yeah or something
like that cheaply shot right like it was
a 90s reality show or some [ __ ] yeah I'm
not sure how many seasons it went into
but when I watched it and I watched it
here and there too because I was like I
was a [ __ ] and then they come back and
then they review their life
yeah they talked about it and they had
them play games yeah but that was like
one of my favorite Playboy TV shows did
and it was so funny because I would just
watch some of these guys be really
uncomfortable when the girls would talk
about [ __ ] but they but majority of
the time I think they enjoyed they get
off watching their wife getting [ __ ]
by somebody else yeah which I don't know
if I could sit there and just watch that
[ __ ] and smile about it well I mean if
they're swingers but that's like that
yeah that's their thing I was some weird
[ __ ] dude I want to do it I want to do a
house I'll call it like political house
but then it's like the extreme version
so we have like straight-up like alright
with like do something super communist
and like somebody like it yeah that [ __ ]
let's see let's see you last even one
episode good I would like to go in there
cuz I just don't know anything about
politics I would just walk in I just I
don't know what like remember that show
trading house swapping water they go I
love that [ __ ] dude like wife swap or
some [ __ ] yeah they were switched like
it would be like a Mormon wife yeah
they're like a punk rock band family or
so and they would [ __ ] it was so
Valerius I love that show there was some
really good reality TV shows back in the
day my favorite one had to be a bully
beatdown I love that [ __ ] was dope too
will he be done was does [ __ ] it's
because the bullies are still so like
they think they can fight or they just
against a professional [ __ ] fighter
dude
would actually I heard they would
actually give those people they would
train them to so they could defend
themselves in the cage but you know a
week worth of training is not gonna help
you out with them MMA fighter that's
been training for like twenty years
it wasn't Joe Rogan it was mayhem Miller
oh okay I went a little crazy but mayhem
Miller was the one that was doing it and
there was an episode where mayhem Miller
the host actually fought one of the
bullies and he beat the [ __ ] [ __ ] out
him up dude that [ __ ] I wonder why they
stopped that show that [ __ ] was dull
yeah it only went on for like three or
four seasons but I thought that would
last for a very long time but some of
these dudes like they had Eddie Alvarez
on there they had you know they had
what's-his-name the guy with the vampire
teeth the [ __ ] geo loves
I forgot yeah because I'm talking about
yeah yeah yeah and they had like UFC
champions going there yeah the [ __ ]
Eddie Alvarez like kick this dude in the
[ __ ] face and then the more you see
the story the more satisfying it is to
all you're just like oh man this [ __ ]
deserves it man they would make money on
the show too right
I think they made money yeah if they won
or something yeah so they would walk
away with like five grand he had that
bully beat up I mean that's not bad at
all
yeah yeah I think with the bully made
money too if you want cuz it was like a
bet yeah if they survived the round or
something they would win like a grand or
something but they would always get
tapped out or something yeah I mean how
are you gonna fight out like a pro
fighter at that type I always thought
that they weren't getting [ __ ] up hard
enough like you did we just get
submitted or summat boy yeah some of
them like some of these UFC fighters
because if they experience bullying
themselves yeah we were younger they
would channel that anger onto that
person like Eddie Alvarez beat the [ __ ]
out of that one guy yeah like he beat
the [ __ ] living crap out of those
guys been bullied that's why they did
martial arts like um George st. Pierre
oh yeah he said that he's been bullied
like hardcore
he brought his life and then that's when
he joined like coach in karate and then
he did really well in that so he decided
to go into like mixed martial arts he
told the story to where he uh he met his
bully when he was older yeah and then
when he met his bully when he was older
I guess like I don't know what it was it
was something along the lines of like
George st. Pierre he was like down and
out of his luck and then George st.
Peter decided to help him out and that's
how nice of a duty is because I saw a
guy that blown me when I was younger
like to the point it was like it's not
like
regular bullying either it's a beer [ __ ]
yeah I would have choked the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of them but I guess you know if
you're a world champion doesn't true I
feel like once you [ __ ] get to a
certain level when you [ __ ] up all these
guys then what does it do for you yeah I
mean what's the point you know and I
mean it's hard not to bully him cuz he
has I mean he sounds like Kermit the
Frog please don't hit me but if he was
in your neighborhood as kids it'll be
hard not it would be hard not to point
that out like it's I don't know but I
don't think I would have bullied him
that hard I just would have made fun of
him he had a it was interesting because
he even mentioned two on that I think he
was on the Joe Rogan podcast but he was
talking about just having empathy for
people because I guess the kid that
bullied him he just get beat by his dad
a lot yeah so he took it out on him so
he took a torch and that was the only
way that that kid knew how to
communicate things and he grew up in a
very broken home and that his that kids
dad used to either I think it was like
beat up his mom or some [ __ ] to hug so
there was just a lot of like just
violence in that kids households yes how
he learned how to deal with it and it
was expressed in bullying George st.
Pierre yeah it's always a cycle man like
I always say like people are only like
halfway responsible for what they do
yeah because I mean where do kids learn
that [ __ ] from that's someone someone
teaches them that you know like that's
true person no one's like born
aggressive and and [ __ ] mean yeah
yeah but you wanted to talk about the oh
right to the topic of the podcast today
so the topic of today is there's been
you know this circulating all over the
internet yeah but it's it's when you see
the video it's just all you see is a
group of kids with megawhatts
surrounding this Native American dude
yeah drum yeah and then like you see the
kids face it's all smug he's like
smiling at him and then like the way
that it was presented was look at these
bunch of Magha kids that are harassing
this Native American yeah now like
initially when I saw that video have you
seen it so I saw the video and I kind of
when I first saw it I started getting
really mad right like I started making
my blood boil and the reason why is
because there's something about that
kids [ __ ] exactly his [ __ ] face
like I saw his face I was like that's
the face that you just want to [ __ ]
smash your [ __ ] right and you know I
think like when we watch media and stuff
like this we do understand that it's
only from one point of view and we never
got to see it from the beginning yes so
I kind of just like rested on it but
then I kept watching the video over I
don't over I didn't like his reaction
his reaction it was so it looked like
that person that he was taunting was
beneath him yeah and it started making
me [ __ ] bad yeah if I could Tim
showed me as a Tim why he showed me this
dude's me angry and in the part that we
saw was a bunch of white kids just
mocking the native dude in mocking his
song and all that stuff yeah so yeah it
just seemed like something we've seen
before yeah you know like in it I think
it brought up a lot of immediate like
negative emotions like even me I was
like if I was this kid's dad man I
[ __ ] smack this I smoked a smack the
[ __ ] smug off his face yeah cuz it
just is so disrespect y'all the thing
that kind of irritated me too
was when you watch that video clip
there's parents there yeah and they
weren't doing [ __ ] they're laughing they
were yeah yeah it's like okay because
there was the I remember reading
comments they're like well oh if their
parents weren't there maybe they want a
handle there's these [ __ ] kids like
hold on their parents were there they
were they were there yeah even their
chaperone or teacher or whatever they
were all on a field trip so the back
story behind it is these kids they they
come from a Catholic school yeah it's
like an all-boys school called like
Covington or something like that yeah
and they were there to protest a
pro-life thing mm-hmm and on the same
day you know in Washington DC if you
guys ever been there there's like
there's all there's a lot of like
protests or marches or things going on
on the same day mmm okay or there's just
people there like saying when they they
got to say to you government right yeah
so the so the boys are there to promote
pro-life they they're there on this
field trip with their school and while
they were there on the steps there is
this extremist group called the black
Israelites or like the Hebrew is like
Israelites right so they're always
around a new yo
or wherever they are and and they're
just spouting out crazy racist [ __ ] all
day long like they're like they're like
if they're like the black version of the
Westborough like oh yeah yeah it's true
like I've heard about them before about
oh yeah so their whole spiel is like the
real Jewish people are Africans
okay and in like they have their own
idea of what history was they think that
history's been whitewashed and like and
you know I just did a little research on
them and and I don't know everything
about them but but to me they are an
extremist group so they were standing
there shouting out [ __ ] to the kids and
there's like this whole two-hour from
beginning to end of how it happened yeah
and they were saying some really
fucked-up [ __ ] like Oh future school
shooters like white this and they were
saying some really racist [ __ ] toward
the kill I actually do remember a clip
of a few black Israelites that went
viral where a lady approached them and I
don't remember who was right or wrong I
don't think I was really looking at that
but it went viral because I guess one of
the guys like rapping the word to the
floor yeah because they got into an
altercation yeah she started it but
obviously the the violence in it it's
the part that right escalation happened
but they're yeah they're just like
they're just angry you know like they're
cussing out the kids and all that stuff
and to me like I mean their kids like
why are you doing it but they're I think
they're the ones that kind of set off
this tension and then the kids are kind
of there in a circle just you know like
being themselves just yelling back and
it's like kids would do like yeah just
yell back and in the native dude his
name is uh Nathan Phillips yeah so his
point was what he wanted to do is defuse
the situation by playing some Native
American music oh yeah and I think it's
it's a it's a it's a chance to like
chill everything out so he was in
between so he started to walk in between
both of them and then he walked up to
the group so here's where things get
kind of [ __ ] up is like originally the
way that it was reported was that the
boys surrounded the Native American guy
and then taunted him yeah so it's so it
makes it seem like it was a it was a
attack that they went out of their way
to do exactly and then um you know and
in the Nathan Phillips dude like he also
kind of told his perspective in a way
that was not so favorable to the kids
yeah because you know he didn't say in
the very beginning like I walked up to
the boys he says he was saying some
other stuff and then but then now he
cleared it up and he says yeah I walked
up to them hmm so then people thought
that the boys initiated the the the
first whatever was going on uh so that's
why I I didn't look that far into it I
just saw the look and I just exactly now
that's what we see in the aftermath of
course I don't like that kids look
either and I didn't like any of that
stuff but in the way that it played out
there's so much this is this is what I
hate about the most like the way that
the the media just kind of took the
narrative and made it all [ __ ] up yeah
is what what is really dividing this
country because the people that are kind
of standing up for the kids they're
saying at the end of the day like these
kids are getting doxed they're under 18
we've all like done stupid [ __ ]
but at the same time like you know we're
all picking on kids layout leave them
alone right that's their argument yeah I
mean and then the other side of the
argument is like those kids were
disrespectful which which they were yeah
and and then you know like they they
were harassing the native dude and in
like everybody's trying to talk about
other people's intentions yeah I'm just
clearly looking at what happened yeah
and what happened was the native dude
stepped up to to the to the school kids
yeah and while he was playing the music
and drumming the black is or Israelites
or whatever he was calling out the black
kids in the group of white kids yeah
and in hue they were calling them like
Coons and like we're like or maybe they
didn't use the word but they were using
that word of like backstabber yeah and
then the black kids were just like we're
here to do the pro-life [ __ ] like yeah I
don't know like it was just crazy
because you
see these full-grown adults yelling and
attacking these children yeah and
they're obviously teen boys you know and
then when the they didn't show this part
but when the when the native dudes were
talking to the white kids there was this
one native dude that was like go back to
Europe you know you guys don't belong
here and all that and I'm like this is a
[ __ ] kid bro like yeah why are you
showing so much aggression toward it
tore a [ __ ] high school kid you're a
you're an adult yeah you know but I
think all sorts of [ __ ] went wrong in
that moment because it was tense and
then I think the Nathan Phillips guy his
what he was trying to do was he says he
was trying to defuse the situation
yeah but some of the boys took it as
he's being aggressive yes beating a drum
in front of my face that's aggressive
that's how he they took it as right so I
don't really know like no one knows but
the point is I the media would the way
that they reported it was oh here's this
guy who's a Vietnam vet he can be
disrespected and disrespected his
culture is being disrespected which I
kind of slide with I don't know but um
yeah just came out to that he's not even
a Vietnam vet mmm he is a veteran like
he was in the Marines but he didn't get
deployed to Vietnam so there's a lot of
misinformation you know the the I think
the hard part is is just you know we all
get entrenched in our own views and what
there's a there's a confirmation bias
that a lot of people have I'm guilty of
that too
yeah the moment I saw that [ __ ] video
I got angry like that as well and even
then like I kind of posted something on
Twitter like I was just irritated I was
like you know this is why you should be
[ __ ] kids ass like this is why you
should get [ __ ] up right and I really
did think that and you know even after
hearing all these facts yeah - this is
probably my confirmation bias yeah
because I saw that face growing up a lot
well it's because we've all experienced
that kind of bullying from white kids
yeah so then or even as a [ __ ] adult
right like I've experienced that [ __ ]
that smug face that I'm on descending
laughs that you know it's just different
yeah and when you see it again and then
when I saw the whole video I was like oh
[ __ ] I know how that happened
like they could have just been scared
and that kids like I'm standing my
ground yeah you know what I mean like
cuz he came up to the hip him yeah but
then what what that did was trigger a
past memory it's not that it's it's what
we thought was very separate from what
happened exactly so then you know it
makes me kind of sad to where I look at
that and I'm supposed to be somebody who
a night and I preach about the [ __ ] to
where it's like Gil let's let's let's
chill out and kind of like collect your
thoughts and look into some of these
facts but then you know that
confirmation bias that I have mm-hmm I
already made up my mind despite the
facts alagesh yeah you know but even
then I still think about it and I still
understand why people are still angry
yeah it's because even after said fact
yeah there were still kids that were
laughing at that guy just you know
barking at him and let's say it was the
black Israelites that did start the
stuff yeah well they they still pointed
their aggression at the wrong person
right and so there's still that issue
that they can't there's no excuse for
that yeah so it's hard to move past that
part and I think even that's why when
people bring up the black Israelites I
think well from what I was reading
everybody saying what does that have to
do with what you did to this guy yeah
you know but you like you said tensions
were already high yeah they started this
high tense environment so people make
mistakes but the thing is no matter what
man the adults that were chaperoning
these kids there's photos of them just
standing there yeah they could have used
this opportunity to step in and baton
like yell like this is how you [ __ ]
deal with a tense situation you know
like an adult they were just standing
and watching and it doesn't help with
the whole case of them saying well
they're just kids well there were adults
too all right we're doing the same thing
and so that means that they learned that
from somebody mm-hmm right and it was
probably from those adults back there
that think that it's okay yeah and it's
weird too in this situation because I
think in this space or the space that
we're in now everything goes online and
it's really hard for people to get away
with the things that they do yeah but on
top of that it can be skewed depending
on what they put exactly dude cuz I I
try to research both like I already like
you know what the right has to say about
it and I'll read what the left has to
say about it
and they both make
sense to me yeah so it's difficult for
me to side I just try to understand what
what both are concerned about yeah and
in what the right is concerned about is
like hey let's keep the kids out of this
let's let's not Doc's these kids yeah
you know like and I mean like [ __ ]
happens
but um you know let's they're focusing
on the kids basically yeah and in what
the left is like saying is like teacher
[ __ ] kids yeah
and in and you know what there's like a
double whammy to this - yeah because
it's a Catholic [ __ ] school so people
associate like Protestant religion with
love yeah kindness and acceptance and so
there's just criticism coming from both
in from just from like a societal thing
and then also a religious thing it's
like you aren't you supposed to be a
Catholic school yeah aren't you supposed
to have like these Protestant beliefs so
what the [ __ ] are you teaching so not
only does it do dis like it does a
terrible injustice to just like how the
youth is yeah but also to the actual
religion that they're supposed to
represent and so there was just like I
just read a lot of comments about that
to like ule isn't this a Catholic school
what the [ __ ] and I you know what do you
say to that yeah you know for sure I
mean and this isn't to excuse it but
there's other kids that had experiences
with this school like doing this is this
one gay kid that got beat up by the
students they're [ __ ] there's like all
the Turks coming out yeah there's like a
basketball athlete that was charged with
rape and I mean like no school is
perfect perfect yeah cuz there's there's
there's I mean they're drug dealers in
my school I [ __ ] did dirt like you
know but the thing is a lot of people
don't understand that that specifically
this school what I read about it is it's
one of those private schools when like
kids get in trouble and if their parents
are rich then they send them off to like
these kind of schools like Bart went to
military school and things like that
yeah so it's like a group of kids that
are kind of like you know they're all
they're all trying to reform themselves
or like the adults are trying to reform
them you know and you know to your point
it was kind of hard to say like are you
gonna look up for specific negative
instances and kind of blame
whole school for ya cuz we could have
done that for both of our high schools
and we got wave was she nude yeah that's
why I'd be a hypocrite just to play like
mr. morality like I'm like [ __ ] dude I
[ __ ] up hard in high school dude I
watched dude this is girl named Nancy in
high school that was chilling on campus
and her boyfriend Jimmy walked up to her
in the inn he was either after school at
lunch I think it was after school yeah
comes up Sox are right in the [ __ ]
nose blood everywhere and he just walks
off campus yeah like we got stories for
days about my high school dude like so I
don't know those type of instances are a
good way to represent a whole school
because we could do that for any [ __ ]
high school in terms of like people who
have done like things that were sexual
misconduct wise violence yeah you know
vandalism got all that stuff so I don't
know I don't know about that I think
that's why though the right brings up
the point about kids will be kids
because we all we all done [ __ ] like
that you know when we hear that it
sounds like they're just dismissing the
behavior they're like well kids will be
kids just let it be
yeah and then it's like nah dude you got
to use this opportunity to like to set
an example
yeah or teach or like you know I don't
know and I think - it just kind of moves
beyond the kids will be kids things
because the adults were there so it's
more like these people are trying to be
like this forever I mean if anyone's
responsible it is the [ __ ] adults a
chaperone yeah they were there to
[ __ ] watch over them and they weren't
watching over them yeah I don't I like I
still don't understand that part because
even in my school when when [ __ ] went
down or you know if something like that
went down there would be an adult that
would tell people to get the [ __ ] back
and go to class or move on they wouldn't
let them go around start chanting in
front of somebody and be like what the
[ __ ] yeah that was the weird part for me
that made no sense yeah I don't know man
it's just it's just kind of [ __ ] up
and I want to talk I want to touch upon
like why we're so separated - because I
have some data and did some research on
like a lot of people wanted me to
further like talk about the Russian
involvement in our country yeah sounds
like a conspiracy but no I mean like I
think it was Dateline or frontline
what's that channel one of those
channels but they they did a two-hour
documentary I mean if this is a
legitimate like old school journey
list right yeah like this is not like
some new publication that just stopped
putting up I mean like it's yet they
have to get evidence before they post
this kind of [ __ ] well you know Russia's
involvement within our government I mean
I think I mean obviously like American
Russia has always had a very like
tumultuous relationship yeah and
especially after this past election yeah
so many things are being uncovered about
Russia's involvement with our election
and everything else and so it's just
this reoccurring theme that keeps
popping up so I think for me when I hear
stuff about Russia I don't know it's
because whether I have gotten
desensitized to so much negative
[ __ ] going on in the country that I
don't even care to listen sometimes
because it's like Oh what else I mean
they're they're one of the biggest
reasons why Americans are so polarized
and separated because you you know
recently Zuckerberg had to go on trial
oh yeah this right where his like
negligence and how he ran Facebook and
things like that right yeah it's because
they were getting like warnings from
everybody saying like yo Russians are
[ __ ] doing something but we don't know
what it is but you guys gotta look into
it during that time their security team
on Facebook was like five ten people or
something and we're gonna mount like
[ __ ] with a user base of like a billion
do that right so Russia like you you
heard a troll farms government okay so
there's government-funded hacker groups
and like troll groups so basically like
your job for eight hours a day or
whatever it is is the talk [ __ ] exactly
so you but it goes further than just
talking [ __ ] you create accounts like
your John from Milwaukee I'm I'm freakin
Joe from LA you create these accounts
right and then you're very like you'll
be you'll be the alt right and I'll be
like LGBT Joe or whatever yeah and then
we'll go into these different forms and
we'll start fighting and fighting and
fighting it will create Facebook groups
and and we'll start cultivating yeah
like-minded individuals
yeah we'll create like like they were
responsible for a lot of our our
protests and stuff yeah so there was
this one incidents and then the CIA or
FBI they traced this and then they can
prove this so what they did was there's
a mosque in Dallas or or or in Texas
somewhere and they created like an
extremist Muslim group yeah and then
they created like a like a very like
alt-right like anti Muslim group they
brought members in Texas into this group
and in and in they said that we're gonna
protest and on this day and then they
wanted to get both groups to protest on
this day in front of the mosque so they
could fight oh yeah and and they've been
doing that all around this country so
like some of the some of these extremist
groups that we've been getting and in
wondering why like why is the country so
separated why are these people
constantly fighting a lot of it is
because of the Russian troll farms and
then I wouldn't be surprised if some of
them came in to JK news and came in to
like YouTube got really toxic you know
and imagine if yours if you're getting
paid to just sit there and talk [ __ ] all
day long but not only that create
Facebook groups create like web sites
create fake news like all of this [ __ ]
like if if you're getting paid to do
that you have so much time to just sit
there and develop like like drama yeah
and a lot of people they're so blind
they like when you read a negative
comment right you think it's just a
person in America talking to you yeah
you don't think it's like a Russian
troll farmer with a like you you could
even look at their Facebook and it's
like oh they used a different person's
picture you know they have a fake
profile all this stuff yeah and it looks
like a real guy and then these guys are
out there constantly trying to [ __ ]
people up like the American culture like
they're using our democracy against us
yeah yeah what is so that so their
purpose in their goal is is what
destabilize the United States make us
keep us busy fighting each other
you know and in like ultimately within
the powers of Nations right like there's
money battles going on there's political
battles going on there's all these
things and in it's like if our resources
are are being used up like trying to
keep things under control in house then
we're gonna be less worried about what's
happening out there it's it's hard in
America just because I don't know if a
lot of people understand this but
America is huge the United States you
know so when we compare like our sense
of like nationalism to another countries
it's hard to say because just think
about this alone California as a state
the population wise it's like another
country in it of itself Texas yeah
another country in and of itself yeah
and they all have separate cultures and
because the United States is just it's
just like 50 nations that kind of just
combined into one it's hard to create
this single sense of nationalism and
everybody has their own ideals and so
we're just like a country that kind of
just argues with it with within itself
all the [ __ ] time yeah I don't get
sometimes I don't get this sense of like
when people say I'm proud to be an
American I feel like everybody's
definition is vastly different for some
races you know because when I when I see
like nationalism or like pride in your
country in another country it seems to
be like the same definition right but
here it's it seems to be extremely
different depending on where you're at
where you're from and where you're going
well the core the core values supposed
to be our Constitution yeah that's
supposed to that's what the course is
supposed to be is the freedom and the
freedom of ownership in the freedom of
speech yeah and things like that which i
think is kind of under threat right now
because it's so polarized that the left
is going even more left yeah
and then what's dangerous about that is
like they want to be more socialist and
they want to be more one yeah in a way
that's that's kind of closer to
communism
I mean if anybody's listening to this
right now I think the biggest thing that
people have to realize is how much of
the content you see is controlled by
somebody exactly and it's so hard to
explain this because they think it's
conspiracy it's not [ __ ] conspiracy
no it is
[ __ ] fact the stuff that you see on
your Facebook it's literally modified
and geared towards the stuff that you
already have a bias on so you just get
more entrenched into stuff that you want
to think so for example red and blue
states the Facebook stuff that you see
politically completely different right
exactly it's going to become even on my
newsfeed on my on my phone yeah when I
was in Arizona I was like telling just
like hey look like all of this news is
Fox and in Republican stuff yeah and as
soon as we come back into California all
the news feeds that pop up I'm like oh
yeah crazy people don't realize that
yeah they think that's [ __ ] they're
like no these are facts even facts I
don't know what facts are anymore yeah I
don't I don't know like even statistics
what a [ __ ] statistics now there's
always a bias in it right I don't know
there is no like clear definition of
truth anymore it's just people want to
see what they want to see and even when
they give out like numbers and metrics
even those are skewed yeah so now I'm
just sitting here like I I don't know
what to believe anymore
I mean I've I've been kind of knowing
and saying this for like the past ten
years right because I think my family
members are all like in pretty they're
pretty smart they're into different
things like my brother's a researcher
and he's told me like you know all of
research it's all business or government
funded and there's an agenda like he's
worked for chocolate companies and they
they pay you lots of money and you kind
of want to find positive things about
chocolate you know so like he's he told
me like yeah like when they advertised
green tea is this and that he's like
it's true but it's a white lie because
you need to drink gallons of it for it
to work yeah like Mars the Mars company
they got in trouble for saying like
chocolate does this and it's good for
you but then like they don't tell you
all the negative stuff like oh well it
has a [ __ ] ton of sugar and in like if
you actually you know if for it to be
effective you need two pounds of
chocolate yeah then they find one
research out and then they get now
promote it right so I thought that dude
they keep telling me chocolate was good
for you right look at me now then now
it's like it's like a common truth that
everyone thinks that it's true
because it's promoted right and then now
it's like it's almost like it's almost
like carrots carrots make you see better
like that that goes out and everyone
thinks you care you could see better
yeah right yeah it fixes your eyesight
but it doesn't it doesn't do any any of
that yeah so it's like there's just a
lot of things that's been happening for
dead like for years and years and years
yeah and we've just been blind for a
really really long time so if I would if
I were to say these things back in a day
right people will be like oh you [ __ ]
conspiracy theorists no don't talk don't
don't talk to crazy Joe like he's just
saying crazy [ __ ] it's because people
are not ready to listen because it is
depressing to understand that nothing is
for sure like confirmed yeah so what are
facts and in it's like a lot of people
are in this position now and I think
that's why there's so much depression
and [ __ ] going on because everyone's
just like I don't know what to believe
everything's been a [ __ ] lie and like
their whole idea of reality is all
[ __ ] up now now I start to understand
flatters people a little more cuz
they've been lied to so much yeah like
oh maybe the earth really is flat now I
don't know what the [ __ ] drive me
[ __ ] any problem and he Bravo got it
right and [ __ ] psychopath yeah you
know also like a lot of people aren't
trained to think like like you know even
if you go to college right you know a
lot of people that went to university
but they didn't apply themselves they
don't know how to think critically yeah
like they'll hear something from their
friend and that becomes fact they read
something on a newspaper that becomes
fact like there's no they don't know how
to look at the research and go like oh
yeah this is something that I can't
believe in because you know there's
evidence yeah and then sometimes they
look at a [ __ ] meme and then they see
a stats chart and they go that's
evidence yeah you know anything like
that they don't know that's what like I
just I like the phrase just agree to
disagree sometimes now cuz yeah I just
let it go don't be so emotionally
invested man like who the [ __ ] cares man
because I see especially and this is not
even an age thing adults probably
arguably do this more than young people
because I see it on Facebook whenever I
do go on yeah which is one of the
biggest reasons why stop going on
Facebook because it's just a bunch of
old [ __ ] argue
about [ __ ] that doesn't [ __ ]
matter I feel like they're the worst
they're the worst and they and they [ __ ]
on these kids so much they're like oh
you kids don't know [ __ ] and all you do
is argue all day about dumb that's you
jackass that's every time there's like
dude I hate it when [ __ ] old people
make memes it's some of the most unfunny
[ __ ] ever dude yeah they just write like
a political meme and then it's all
people laughing I'm like this is not
funny at all you old [ __ ] yeah what are
you talking about dude and the older we
get too I hope I don't become like that
I know I'm like am I gonna be like that
am I gonna be making jokes like that
[ __ ] [ __ ] I think it's just people
who are stubborn it's not really old
people like people that don't want to
learn yeah because there's plenty of
older people that I guess like they stay
relevant they stay current because they
still want to grow and learn and study
and involve their minds it's just such
an odd space to be in man like now I
truly understand why people say
ignorance is bliss yes you can't be hurt
by things you don't know dude I wish I
was a giggly [ __ ] that just I
know like Oh things happen yeah that's
why those country bumpkins are few [ __ ]
yo we know somebody right now this girl
is very sweet but this [ __ ] dude like
if she if she jumped up in the air you
would hear marbles in her brain like she
looks so [ __ ] happy yeah and I envy
that sometimes like she could be in the
worst situation on earth it doesn't
[ __ ] matter because those two little
paper clips and thumbtacks are fighting
each other in her brain that's the only
thing that [ __ ] matters dude she's so
carefree I know I wish I could be like
her sometimes it's all about living in
the present man and I think like what
I'm glad that I know all these things
but the thing is you don't want to
obsess yeah you got to control your
emotions cuz it's like once you know you
have the power because knowledge is
power what do you do with it yeah like
you know there's really nothing - I
think - when you guys or when people in
general create a group of friends I
think one of the healthiest things or
the healthiest type of person to have
within your group or the people are
people who can have a discussion about
something disagree and just be okay with
it a hundred percent I mean that's like
us right yeah we all have different
beliefs like like you have a you're
Christian
and I'm not Christian but I can respect
that yeah you have faith in that
religion I'm not gonna knock you for
that yeah there's a lot of different
things that we might believe in but that
doesn't take away the relationship we
have as friends and I think that's how
we should approach America right like
people that live in the country who you
know have totally different ideals maybe
they're devout Christians or whatever
like they we should respect that and be
okay with it maybe even have a
conversation and try to learn like each
other's lifestyles or whatever like not
too long ago too like I was in a college
show and this kid asked me um you know
my religious preference right you also
what are you I was like I'm Christian
little well how can you say that you're
Christian when you curse and you do all
these other things nowhere in the Bible
says thou shalt not cuss yeah I'm not
saying that I'm perfect but these are my
set of beliefs yeah and you know what I
was trying to explain this young man he
goes well don't you think that's like a
waste of time there's no facts behind it
I was like well faith faith is in fact
right and it's just something that that
keeps me whole as a person and so he's
getting arguably irritated because he
wants to control his world yeah like
those kind of people they want they want
to wake you up yeah and I'm looking at
him and I go okay well definitively for
you right so why don't you think it
exists and he goes this this and that he
goes well for me I'm not trying to
convince you that my world exists I'm
just telling you this is what makes me
happy so for you to sit there and tell
me that this is a waste of my time it's
irrelevant because I'm happy you're the
one that's upset wasting your time
talking to an idiot then if I'm the
idiot yeah why are you wasting your
breath on me the dumb person that
reminds me a good like hardcore movie or
comic guy or whatever it is they're so
into their [ __ ] if you tell them that
what they like sucks don't fight you to
[ __ ] and just to convince you why it's
good yeah and so I'm looking at this kid
and you know like I'm always open to
have these type of conversations and I'm
just telling him it's like okay I'll say
well let me just give you another
alternative thought let's just say God
doesn't exist
but I did my best to follow this
religion and it made me happy right mhm
and the end result is that I died with
the purpose and I felt good about it
yeah did I waste my life or not yeah and
the and you know he was like well you
could have done we're not talking about
that
talking about what your end goal is if
my end goal is to live happy and follow
something that keeps me as a person
whole then I guess I was very fulfilled
right and what's the up what's the other
side what's the other side that if he
does exist you know what I mean what's
the negative to this yeah as long as my
happiness and what I'm doing doesn't
obstruct what you're doing right then
you should be kind of cool with it
because right now we just had our
conversation about you being mad we
thought you're mad because I believe in
this being that you can't prove exists
yeah it's like that and that's cool with
me broke yeah like if I said to you that
I'm not coming up to you saying hey bro
just to let you know Shane's gonna [ __ ]
you in the ass and you're you're
gambling with some Satan dick right now
bro like you don't even know right now
see you're not believing in God guess
what on that other side there's a
pitchfork in your mouth with a [ __ ]
spiny dick up your ass I'd say that's
[ __ ] you right now you're not scared
of that I can't have this conversation
like that you know like it's it's it's
so weird like I that conversation it
didn't even entertain me it's just I
didn't understand why he couldn't just
walk away and say well I said they're
not fighting you it's like imagine what
if their parents were devout Christians
that forced them to go to church and and
he has all this pain and and and and
he's yelling at you about that yeah like
like he's taking it out on you yeah
because he couldn't take it on on his
parents it's the same it's the same
thing with like people that like let's
say let's say like if if something
racist happened to you right yeah some
white guy like like called you [ __ ] or
whatever and then like next time you
have an opportunity to tell another
white guy off you're taking it out on
some perhaps they'll be valid in the
past right and I think I think these
people that are just angry and and just
they don't have a point to their
argument they just want to [ __ ] take
out their aggression on [ __ ] there's
something that happened to them and
they're just taking all that negative
energy and trying to unleash it on you
yeah there was and I think that's that's
all it is man there was also a producer
that I worked with Han [ __ ] yeah and he
I guess like within his family he had
missionaries in his family but whatever
experience that he had with his
missionary mother or father or whatever
that it was I'm not sure if it was his
dad
but either way left a very poor taste in
his mouth yeah and every time the topic
of religion comes up he just [ __ ]
goes off Wow with a stupid [ __ ] list
but you know let me tell you this real
quick about religion bro so shut the
[ __ ] nobody [ __ ] cares yeah sometimes
people don't understand time in place
Yeah right yeah there's there's like
there's a reason why people say at the
dinner table you don't bring up what
religion policy money yeah you just want
to have a pleasant conversation and eat
good food yeah people social skills
people but [ __ ] social social skills
like even with a kid who brought it up
yeah I'm okay with it but it's like bro
I just met you man
yeah I don't give up but like does he
think he's gonna change your mind like
you're gonna go you know what you're
[ __ ] right yeah there's no facts
behind it you [ __ ] taught me so much
today yeah what the [ __ ] you think is
gonna happen now I pray every night ya
Satan will [ __ ] me ass that's all I'm
praying now it's like I do the most
ungodly [ __ ] now I'm like God if you
could just please just shoot one tornado
right into the socket of his eyes please
please throw him in the eye of a
hurricane yeah that's the thing I don't
understand sometimes how people don't
they're just not sociable they don't
understand how to socialize with right
it's like the comments you know like
when you see people arguing in the
comments back and forth back and forth
back and forth like to me it's a fun
sport it's fun but I can tell that for a
lot of people this is real life they
yeah like they're in it you know like
they're really trying to debate and
fight somebody over the Internet it's
like that's weird I read this [ __ ]
comment that furious Pete wrote yes so
furious Pete is a youtuber who he's a
competitive eater yeah he owns his own
like fitness apparel the guys are very
highly successful guy from Canada
amazing dude super nice guy but he
survived testicular cancer once and then
he actually found out that he had to get
surgery to remove his other testicle
again yeah so and he has been going
through a lot so he had testicular
cancer once it got removed so his
testicle was three times the size of the
other one it was hard testicular cancer
got it removed survived yeah and I guess
what happens after or what I'm not sure
how typical it is but the cancer will
move up somewhere else yeah and then I
think he went through chemo for that
yeah fought it defeated it again so
strong
dude strong guy and so later on he found
out whatever this chemical that's in his
body for four male it should be zero but
it was at a ridiculously high number
anything above zero that's a sign that
you could have like testicular cancer so
he got him for a checkup and he found
out it was a big [ __ ] number ow and
then after a month it started going down
down down down down yeah but I think
recently he got his test he had to get
his other testicle removed Wow so he
lost both testicles sucks but you know
he actually did save his healthy sperm
also so they a frozen Yemen is a
girlfriend or fiance yeah we'll be able
to have a kid in the future like in
vitro fertilization or something like
that but somebody wrote a comment right
after somebody goes through something
very serious like this somebody wrote a
very insensitive comment where they said
hey um basically kind of going into the
whole thought of like medicine as a lie
you probably wouldn't have had this
happen if you didn't go to the doctors
and they're just doing this so they
could keep you a medal he had testicular
cancer you [ __ ] [ __ ] nut the guy was
dying his testicle was three times the
size of me this isn't that conspiracy
it's there his ball was the size of the
[ __ ] bowling ball this who probably
watched like an anti vaccination
documentary I like he probably saw like
a big pharma documentary and exact yeah
it's testicular cancer yeah it's not the
common cold you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you
know and he's trying to have like like
what were you trying to do what are you
trying to convert like you know what
dude and it's already done it's done
like what it was like what are you
supposed to do is like is like oh well
thanks for telling me now now I could do
something about it like even if he was
gonna do anything about it he can't it's
already done now he's just gonna [ __ ]
rub something in someone's face even if
it was real like even if all those
conspiracies that he believed that in
place exactly you're you're pretty much
[ __ ] a person that's almost dying
yeah or just beat death you're just you
know [ __ ] kicking them back in the
coffin basically yeah man what a [ __ ]
nuts that's what I'm saying and you know
these people too that I guess I could
his thing goes I'm a huge fan really are
you though bro like I don't know what
fandom really means but if that's the
case that you are I don't know if you
were trying to help him out but that
comic couldn't have come at a worse
[ __ ] time that guy survived cancer
three [ __ ] time
yeah and then you decide to write this
comment and Pete by the way doesn't
respond back to negativity like that
yeah he's very good about that but
something that you said caused him to
respond back yeah which shows the type
of damage that you were doing on his
psyche yeah the guy that doesn't get
fazed by [ __ ] like that the guy survived
cancer three times but you wrote
something that rocked him a little bit
and even then what were you thinking
what was your goal yeah like what was
your point yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
what I'm saying dude like it's such a
it's such a weird thing to deal with now
it's crazy how many people just like
it's it's so weird like they they say
all these crazy things and then they go
oh well you should be able to take
criticism from your fans like why who
are you but sometime like you said time
and place like yeah a lot of the times
they don't see us as human beings yeah
or you know oh if you're if you're so
[ __ ] you know public you should be
able to take it and all these things and
it's like at the end of the day man I
feel like these people are just hurt and
they're not communicating what's going
on correctly yeah you know like it's
almost like I mean we grew up with Asian
dads you know they don't know how to
show and express things and like they
don't know how to be vulnerable what if
this [ __ ] kid is like all Pete I
don't want you to die because I look up
to you but like I'm hurt that like my my
hero is is so vulnerable like my hero
can actually like die you know and then
he takes it out on his hero like like
[ __ ] like that happens all the time but
they don't know how to express
themselves because they grew up in
shitty homes they probably don't get any
communication from their parents yeah
you know like the way these people are
raised and grown like I think like
they're [ __ ] that's why they
communicate the way they do no one
taught them the right way
it gets scary too because it's easier
for people to hide behind a screen now
than it is to ever have to talk somebody
and say to them face to face yeah and I
call them out all the time if I see a
shitty scum and I'm like you afraid to
show your face [ __ ] yeah I'm doing this
thing then 20 19 where I'm like I'm only
going to respond to positive comments
because like I think I've wasted it's
not even a waste of time it kind of is
because okay I'm going
for me I enjoy too much it is it's fun
it's a sport man I enjoy because I'm
sitting there and the only thing I'm
thinking about is how what can I say to
piss this person off for me it's a game
you know so I tried to say something
that'll make them really [ __ ] mad and
that's the only thing I'm thinking about
okay but what about these people who are
supportive of you maybe you should give
them some [ __ ] love instead of always
giving attention to these pieces of [ __ ]
exactly so I'm trying to like flip that
up but sometimes it's [ __ ] hard like
somebody wrote this comment tim kind of
roasted this dude yeah we put up a photo
of us doing the food festival [ __ ] and
this kid wrote Oh what our 30 year olds
doing wearing backpacks like are you
supposed to walk around with a suitcase
or a [ __ ] satchel and you [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] like who doesn't have a
backpack on am I supposed to carry all
my [ __ ] in a [ __ ] grocery bag you
little [ __ ] nut maybe a burlap sack what
the [ __ ] does a backpack have to do with
age you [ __ ] a [ __ ] you're 30
now you should wear a purse yeah you
little dumb [ __ ] you know what how old
are you you're 12 years old don't you
don't you [ __ ] dare drink any type of
milk you son of a [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] what it does for your budgets like
the logic doesn't make any sense I just
wanted a snap this kids [ __ ] neck and
I'm like you know what now all I want to
do is say something to piss you off but
2019 David said you know what David just
let it go you know what's so funny about
this dislike now the way the Internet is
like when I when we first started right
like a good [ __ ] five years plus no
one was trying to be a hall monitor
there's so many [ __ ] hall monitors
now dude like I can't believe I have
younger people try to what but try to
tell me like Oh watch your language and
dress like an adult and do this I'm like
damn full where's your youth man [ __ ] it
I guess some of the wit I say a majority
of might like diehard fans that people
that still watch my stuff yeah they tend
to be fairly intelligent and I think
they like to hear real [ __ ] yeah it's
just there's like a couple people that
trickle and they just piss me off I
think that's always gonna happen right
like I mean you know I always say that
being on a public platform you're gonna
attract crazies yeah and then you know
if you got a million followers of course
come on dude there's gonna be some crazy
in there because
I mean you know sometimes were their
friend that they never had yeah and and
and sometimes you know they have a
relationship with us yeah and we say
something that they don't like and then
they turn on us yeah that happens all
the time it's like I never met you dude
but I said something that really upset
them and then now it's like bipolar
relationship dude it's crazy yeah one of
the biggest things I think I do enjoy
about this space and platform and like
even for me like I always try to figure
out what I want to get out of YouTube
you know not so much in terms of what I
want to put out is what what is my
purpose for doing this space and I
always get refreshed when I meet
somebody that says hey I've been
watching you for five or six years and
you got me through a lot of hard times
and a lot of the advice that you give or
that the times you made me laugh helped
me to become a better person today yeah
and I'm not sure how many people that
works for it but that's like a big
driving force for me me too yeah yeah
percent because if not then you know I
have other options that could mean
there's no if like I'm from a monetary
standpoint there's a lot of other social
media stuff aside from YouTube that I
could be doing yeah you know if this
doesn't make the most money but I think
it's the most rewarding to the soul yeah
cuz like yeah we have the shitty
comments and I think they're the
funniest to talk about yeah but then
there's a lot of great comments
yeah but the times that I feel like I
agree like when I see them face to face
and I'm traveling and I'm doing
meet-and-greets and in like the reach
the impact that we have like all over
the world it's like I'm meeting people
in Australia or across the nation and we
meet face to face and I impacted
someone's life because I was just being
mean and I was just speaking my mind and
living how I wanted to do and it's it's
insane because it empowers other people
to do what they want to just by an
example do sometimes do it I guess so
jealous cuz I'll meet like I met a kid
he was like yeah man I'm in med school
now like I'm doing really want like how
did you surpass me you son of a [ __ ]
but you [ __ ]
there was like when I was doing funny
fat fit when I was losing that so that's
when I only lost like 20 pounds yeah
it's a kid that came up that he goes
dude I lost a hundred pounds but that's
it I'm like you [ __ ] [ __ ] how dare
you do better than me you [ __ ] but
that's that's the cool
a little bit of he's like dude I'm [ __ ]
I'm lagging bro these people losing more
weight they'd be like what the [ __ ] is
going on what am I doing wrong it's like
you gave me advice you push them harder
then yeah push yourselves I'm saying
like I kind of like gave up and they're
still going on like you can do it too
David get your [ __ ] hands off me man
yeah I think what's cool is that we just
get to be ourselves and we stay real and
and then you know like it's we build a
community out of it and like it's it's
almost like us by us trailblazing and us
conquering our own feared fears like it
inspires them to do the same yeah and
that's what it's all about right like
before YouTube before all this stuff
there was no way for all of us to kind
of connect and feel that kind of support
yeah like like when you were venturing
off doing stand-up comedy on your own
there was no real support network for
you yeah and and so now like I see so
many more young people like pursuing
things that they want and becoming
successful way earlier in life because
it makes me so jealous right but it's
it's it's because of you know all of our
peers and us and like we kind of set
that and it makes it easier to when you
see somebody else do it that also looks
like you and you're like I could [ __ ]
do that
yeah and then you get inspired and then
you end up like surpassing them yes I
think even with like Bobby right Bobby
doesn't really understand this but it's
like you know we always tell me you were
a trail blazer for right right for that
I was like all you kids are so
successful at a young age but it's like
well somebody had to do that in front of
us for us to do what we do yeah like
Margaret Cho did it for him yeah and
then he was our inspiration like oh [ __ ]
Asians can be funny yeah so so yeah well
guys that's what are we at like an hour
and 20 minutes that was a good [ __ ]
conversation talked about Russians
talked about [ __ ] stupid idiots
stupids and yeah man so check it out so
we are now officially up on every
platform I'm talking about cast box
Spotify iTunes and if you are there and
you guys can give us a 5-star it would
be very much appreciated thank you very
much and you guys already know we're
gonna get those sponsors real
soon because who doesn't love themselves
some genius brains if you are watching
this on YouTube just make sure that you
leave in the comments below topics you
want us to go over articles all that
good stuff because we're gonna cover all
this [ __ ] and we are here for you that's
genius brains baby yeah baby see ya
later bye my face